all right okay hear me out again
you want some splice all right hear me
out Full Metal Alchemist Brotherhood
sword online
I need you to close okay
we are talking about influential anime
no right anime that has influenced the
industry we're not putting Astro Boy
anything about influence okay look I do
not want to hear that word come from
your mouth look look at how many isekai
area uh anime are airing right now how
much it's like gone it's a fan it's it
you say it's a fad people have been
saying this since Sword Art online and
it's still yet to die in fact it's still
[__] stronger than ever what started
it because of people like you who keep
watching you won't popularize there what
popularized it so what else [__] put
Goblin Slayer on the list for
revolutionizing NTR for goblins player
would not exist without Sword Art Online
Game No Life on the list as well is that
that inspired a bunch of stuff too oh
yeah let's do that again
okay serious one though yeah
what do you guys think about Cowboy
people oh no no no no no no no no no
just thinking purely from the influence
in the west I know like in Japan Cowboy
Bebop wasn't as big but it was a it was
a propagator for anime in the West in
the 90s I agree but I think like death
note did more for for Western anime
I think that's just way more popular I
think Cowboy bebop's influence has been
dying uh with every kind of like year
that passes by yes it was one of the
first anime that kind of like we all saw
on television
um I didn't see that [__] on television
I think Death Note had more influence
than people I agree I think definitely
had more influence especially in the
modern anime era yeah it's crazy
obviously people look at Cowboy people
with more like critical claim
um but yeah I I don't know if I would
put it on uh Elle's theme alone is more
influenced yeah
I'm giving this Cavalry off slander one
actual strong Contender I want to put on
even though people might not talk about
it too much
um nowadays uh Harry suzumia
it it was definitely uh it did
popularize the line okay okay let it won
yes it popularized light novel
adaptations which which I thought which
I argue is the most popular adaptations
we get in anime there are more like
normal adaptations and I think manga
adaptations there are uh and you know
how are he popularized it and if I
needed to name an anime that's
epitomized mid-2000s anime culture it is
[__] Harry it's harihi or Lucky Star
you are you're half right gone you said
mid anime and you're right it is for me
it's anime fans
I think I I would genuinely put Harry on
there because it is such a time capsule
of like the the anime climate of its
time every time capsule it belongs in
the past no one talks about it nowadays
I mean it okay to be fair
yeah as much I kind of agree with Conor
like as much as I [__] love Harry
here and like that climate of the
mid-2000s anime world like it is a hard
show to sell to someone today yeah same
thing with Lucky Star [__] love Lucky
Star but I would not recommend it to
people today lucky stars hear me out for
changing the cosplay game dang and
Romper
just single-handedly making sure cosplay
is always the same sure
very midish anime I remember when junko
cosplayers were like everywhere
oh yandere simulator
if we are we have to put elephant lean
on there yeah
um okay so we have four we need to pick
one to go on we're gonna add sun to this
list okay I still think we should put
Sailor Moon on there yeah well yeah like
you say oh it's a boring choice but hey
it revolutionized so many genres it
popularized anime in the west especially
for a female audience we've literally
made an anime news network list so far
I'm just saying are we are you cool with
that
you know what maybe they're right yeah
for once in their lives maybe they're
right you ever thought about that
one at least like posted a spicy one on
here come on I'm I I mean I'm saying
Harry or Sword Art Online
all right make a better case and name me
name me one that deserves to be on there
more than either of the ones Death Note
entirely Death Note pop culture impact
alone Death Note crushes them both uh
not in Japan not to mention uh Willem
Dafoe uh who might I remind you is
notoriously a large penis uh who also
are the people who like that
that's true by the way but it's a true
fact Google it don't I don't look at
pictures they don't exist I tried
um I in Japan actually in Japan too
there's no Hara he's using me a musical
there's a death or a musical
you can watch it in London yeah I know
all right there is one of the first
penis was so large that after the
filming of the 2009 psychological
Thriller Antichrist the director had to
cut the scene would defose actual penis
and reshoot it with a body tell because
it was so large that everyone in the
room was confused
it is my favorite fact that he has an
extreme thank you damn that's
interesting
so would you say that Death Note
deserves Beyond there more than Full
Metal Alchemist yes yeah
I think that Death Note gen like uh
memes aside now is actually is more
influential more spoken about still to
this day than a lot of these shows and
also I think it was a banger of a show I
think I think it was a ton of memes I
think what Death Note did as well that
was really influential was that it kind
of uh made I guess like the whole
Thriller anime cool it made the whole
Thriller
cool
you like death note
finally gave us an anime that allowed
you to recommend anime people yeah it
may it made it made the darker side of
anime more accessible yeah it made you
uh more likely to get [__] bullied
for having a [__] death note
I just [__] watch it what the [__]
yeah we all know everyone who wants that
[__] in the mid-2000 was like I'm gonna
get one myself
take your name in my death note and it
was like okay
I think you're actually clowning if you
think the Death Note had less impact
than Harry excuse me I'm just okay it's
because I think Death Note definitely
had you know was more popular in terms
of like the widely I think Harry was
just more influential in terms of like
the shaping the kind of landscape we
already have so many of this these kind
of picks on our list let's mix it up a
little bit
mix it up a little bit we're not picking
let's not pick the most influential
let's pick like something
because otherwise people just pick Astro
Boy
it shouldn't be the only thing we're
considering yeah and I think that it
should be saying that like it's a it's
an anime that you kind of have to
experience and watch or uh to like be
considered an anime fan I think death is
one of those Animes
in that definition why is Fullmetal
Alchemist not on there this guy hasn't
watched it God has a whole career
talking about anime
this man's job to watch anime and he
hasn't watched Fullmetal Alchemist and
he's doing fine so I mean that's true
and Full Metal Alchemist I think
almost it's kind of like
I it's such a weird way to describe it I
feel like it we needed a constant number
one and we've just all agreed that it's
good enough to be number one but I think
a lot of people wouldn't actually say
it's their favorite no but I think we
just we like having these constants in
our lives and I think everyone gets a
little bit of comfort from being like
yes Fullmetal Alchemist is it's the safe
choice is a very respectable choice that
we all agree and we all keep for some
reason keeping it at number one yeah uh
because we feel like the story is very
concise it's very well told and very
enjoyable okay in in that it's like a
it's like a measurement of unit but like
you have a we have the meat of somewhere
locked away in France okay if we're
going by that logic then what would you
say other than death note or full metal
what would you say is like another anime
that you would be like okay if you if
you want to get into anime this is the
one that you have to watch
that's a great question uh uh I mean
because then we can use that as a metric
to figure out like okay which one of
them should be I'd say Attack on Titan
that's like yeah that's my go-to-blind
anime recommendation if I don't know if
I know nothing about the person yeah
this is because unfortunately anime has
this issue where if people don't watch
anime they have preconceived notions of
what
animation is and it's for children and
yeah yeah yeah so the reason why often
death Naruto Titan get recommended is
because they're a lot more serious a lot
darker and it's a lot it's a great way
of kind of showing someone want a great
show but also two showing them hey this
whole genre has a vast variety of uh
different topics and yeah some of it is
childish yeah there are a lot of really
mature shows and Stories being told yeah
the whole level of stuff like you know I
know break it's like [__] meme at
this point it's like Breaking Bad you
know storytelling that like is I think
like at the same kind of maturity yeah
yeah no I I agree I think attack Titan
does that so then do we agree in that
case then that attack on Titan should be
up there yeah I mean I'm happy to put it
up there but I did just feel a little
like too soon but I mean yeah I mean if
if we're going something like this I I I
want to like restate my uh stance on one
piece then I think oh man I think
oh that's really epic just balding in
that one huh yeah I mean one piece seems
to be like seems to be the anime that
it's kind of like the anime that
everyone needs to be at least have like
some kind of opinion on now you know
it's it's everyone needs to be up to
date or you need an opinion on like if
we're gonna do that we should get rid of
Dragon Ball
because I don't like Dragon Ball and
I've been very vocal about that okay uh
I think Dragon Ball is Iconic for many
reasons yeah uh mainly because of the
[__] spiky hair uh and that outline
[__] everyone knows Goku yeah
ah actually I can't do it I can't do it
I can't do I can't do it I I mean the
it's it's less of Dragon Ball and it's
more just like the idea of Dragon Ball
you know the idea like it's too iconic
yeah it's too iconic and we just can't
put them both on the list I think I
occupy the same space yeah I think I
think our Judgment of Dragon Ball has
purely been clouded by the fan
if you separate the show from the fan
base the show is [__] fantastic yeah
and highly influential and it's great
fun really easy to get into and the
comments of this on this episode
um okay I had something and I forgot it
now